presidential retreats have a long
history in this country the kennedys had
their cape cod compound in massachusetts
ronald reagan rode horses and
entertained queen elizabeth at his
california ranch
and donald trump's mar-a-lago was
considered the winter white house
now in the biden era rehoboth beach
delaware is the latest executive escape
and kately huey burns gives us a tour
just a couple of hours east of
washington rehoboth beach has been known
by locals as the nation's
summer capital but now with the
president owning a home here
this small seaside town is getting a
moment in the sun
rakobeth is a little different because
it's not isolated
it's not secluded like an island
or a ranch so it's part of a larger
area where everyday americans vacation
the concept of a presidential vacation
dates back
over 150 years says colleen shogin of
the white house historical association
of course the early presidents
uh off you know would retreat back to
their their homes
so probably the first president that
went on a legitimate presidential
vacation
was ulysses s grant and he liked to
vacation
at the jersey shore and so from there
forward we see presidents actually
going on vacation though when you're the
leader of the free world
there's really no such thing as time off
i call upon all nations
to do everything they can to stop these
terrorist killers
thank you now watch this drive but
presidents never really enjoy
that privilege to be able to turn off
being president of the united states a
change of scenery gives presidents the
time to
rejuvenate often gives them time to do
things that they couldn't do
at the white house good morning for the
bidens that means
riding bikes in cape henlopen state park
or visiting local eateries
like lori's cafe one of my employees
said oh my god look who's in line and
i'm like who and i looked up and i'm
like oh my god it's joe biden
after they won we were so happy we were
screaming in here that day and
i said i'm gonna text her so i just said
lori's cafe wishes you all the best you
guys are gonna rock the
white house all the best to you both and
she actually
she emailed me back one of the most
iconic features here in rehoboth is this
one mile boardwalk built in the 1870s
it's a family-friendly place that has it
all pizza
ice cream salt water taffy and chances
are that if you're one of the many who
have been coming here over the summers
you've probably run into one of the
bidens he was even a guest here when he
was vice president
and at that time you might just walk
around town and turn around and poof
there he was
with dr joe biden behind him like most
towns in america rehobeth has had a hard
year
mayor stan mills hopes that its new
status as a presidential vacation spot
will help with tourism and what kind of
impact does that have
on business and the local economy the
idea that the president has a home here
we're actually pleased that joe biden is
putting
delaware and rehoboth beach on the map
not just locally but worldwide
i do think that presidents need to
select
vacation spots that fits their
personality
their own personal preferences and i
think that you know president biden
he's very comfortable at rehoboth and
he's also someone
who you know wants to be who is down to
earth he likes ice cream
there's no shortage of ice cream at
rehoboth i think i'm gonna need one of
those
i have one that's welcome news for chip
hearn whose ice cream shop is a
prominent stop on the boardwalk
this is a homemade ice cream that we
named after the president
biden's summer white house charity this
may be biden's second home but
donald trump won sussex county which
encompasses rehobeth
with 55 percent of the vote in 2020.
still it's not a partisan town politics
here has nothing to do with republican
and democrats
it has to do with who's doing some cool
stuff
and making the beach better and while
vacationers may come here to escape
politics the area is full of u.s history
we're right at herring point which
played a very key role
from world war ii armed it was a former
socialist listening station look
listening for subs and activity out into
the atlantic ocean
as a senator biden helped convert some
of the land from the military back to
the state of delaware
a former u.s navy facility here in the
park now bears his name
i was in this exact spot with him about
three years ago and he was just
another gentleman out bike riding and at
one point he was asking about my family
and he ended up saying hey let's call
your mom
and he talked to my mom on the phone
which was a real treat for her
with security concerns and his larger
entourage
biden has spent less time than usual
here in rehoboth
but that doesn't stop residents from
claiming the president
as one of their own for cbs this morning
saturday
i'm caitlin huey burns in rehobeth beach
delaware
fun staff martha's vineyard his retreat
for two presidents clinton
and obama and i just have to say
i got a chance to see both beach ocean
ice cream in delaware will take it right
ice cream